seize collectivités 19 équipements ont
été retenues pour devenir des centres de
préparation pour les athlètes en 2024
les yvelines auront donc la part belle
pour le grand rendez vous sportif que
sont les jeux olympiques
le gymnase maurice baquet de guyancourt
recevra les entraînements de judo pour
accueillir les sportifs la ville a lancé
la construction de deux salles d'arts
martiaux
les travaux devraient s'achever en juin
coût de l'opération 2 2 à 2 5 millions
d'euros subventionnés je pense que c'est
effectivement liée à ses nouvelles
installations qui vont arriver l'an
prochain et donc qui permettent un
confort d'installation on pense aussi à
la proximité du lieu olympiques puisque
le lyon olympique aura probablement lieu
pour le judo sous la tour eiffel
on s'était un besoin vrai besoin pour la
ville de bus en cours de toute façon du
côté des clayes-sous-bois l'annoncent a
aussi été bien accueillie la commune a
été retenue pour sa piste de bmx situé
dans le parc du carillon est créée en
2010 est en remplacement d'un terrain de
football à notre site et en être
reconnue donc de les équipes devront
choisir parmi les différents sites au
moment des jo et nous espérons que nous
serons choisi par une équipe de haut
niveau et pourquoi pas espérer l'équipe
de france
si une vingtaine de lieux y vit noah est
déjà connu d'autres dossiers sont encore
à l'étude comme l'athlétisme à
guyancourt